bonsoir mardi 4 mai bienvenue dans le
journal de tv 78 c'est l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale voici les titres de
cette édition le territoire concentre
15% de la recherche publique et privée
française paris saclay organise le paris
saclay spring l'événement des acteurs de
l'innovation française qui se déroulera
les 20 et 21 mai prochain reportage et
un invité
jérémy hervé directeur de l'innovation
et du développement économique à le pea
paris saclay une cagnotte lancé pour
emma cette petite fille de 8 ans
habitante dhabi est atteinte d'un grave
cancer ses parents espèrent pouvoir lui
faire bénéficier d'un traitement aux
états unis très coûteux interview du
père de la jeune yvelinoise à suivre
enfin découverte dans ce journal de la
fraiseraie de houdan le couple
d'agriculteurs qui la gère va rouvrir la
boutique à la ferme prochainement après
un an de fonctionnement un drive face à
la crise sanitaire ils ont dû s'adapter
entre volonté de renouer le contact et
regain d'intérêt des consommateurs pour
la production locale et quelques
semaines après le blocage du site agro
paris tech à thiverval grignon la
direction de l'école réagissait à suivre
dans ce journal
en ce jour d'adoption de la loi climat
et résilience à l'assemblée nationale ce
déplacement des ministres de la
transition écologique et des sports
barbares accompli et roxana maracineanu
était à poissy elles ont assisté à la
formation savoir rouler à vélo à l'école
primaire nelson mandela le gouvernement
vient de lancer à ce propos le programme
génération vélo 21 millions d'euros pour
déployer l'apprentissage du vélo et des
enfants de 6 à 11 ans ce programme est
destiné à accompagner des communes et
des structures accueillant des enfants
pour les former au savoir rouler à vélo
le parti présidentiel qui vient
d'annoncer ses candidats pour les
élections départementales dans les
yvelines la république en marche a
présenté ce matin ces binômes cinq
femmes et cinq hommes s'engagent pour le
scrutin des 20 et 27 juin prochains les
précisions dans ce sujet de mélanie poké
engagé pour le 78 c'est sous cette
bannière que la république en marge des
yvelines dans sa campagne le parti
présidentiel a fait le choix de ne
présenter que cinq binômes pour les
élections départementales
on a eu un travail de réflexion pour
être cohérent avec nos choses élections
municipales on a fait d un certain
nombre de deux d'alliance qui nous a
permis d'entrer dans les conseils
municipaux de travailler avec différents
maires du territoire et pour nous il est
indispensable que le travail au niveau
départemental soit cohérent avec ça elle
démarches à engager dès la création du
parti des nouveaux adhérents mais aussi
des élus comme des conseillers
municipaux ou encore des mères les
binômes sont hétéroclites
je pense qu'ensemble on va beaucoup plus
loin et on s'est regroupé nos trois
comités existants se sont regroupés pour
faire un seul comité et permettent
d'avoir une task force pour les
prochaines échéances électorales à
commencer par cette départementale et à
deux sujets qui me semble important
c'est la mission sociale du département
rendu encore plus important de tirer du
fait de la crise sanitaire
c'est l'exigence d'amélioration
d'efficacité de ces des services publics
à tous les niveaux administratifs et je
pense que pour cela il faut changer de
méthode se présentent aussi qu'a déjà
moudni bonne candidate aux dernières
législatives dans la 8e circonscription
des yvelines
grégory pape conseiller municipal de
guyancourt ou encore laurent de bastard
médecin urgentiste à versailles avec ses
dix candidats la république en marche
souhaiterait installer un débat au sein
du conseil départemental
l annonce de la vente du domaine par
l'état avait provoqué le blocage des
lieux pendant plusieurs jours l'école
agroparistech va quitter thiverval
grignon un départ provoquées par le
regroupement des quatre sites
franciliens de l'établissement à
palaiseau en essonne et bien qu'aucun
promoteur n'est encore acquis le site
l'annnonce de la vente avait entraîné un
mouvement des étudiants en mars dernier
quelques semaines après la direction de
l'école a accepté de réagir et c'est au
micro de bixente n'a rien senti steban
oui on a bien sûr beaucoup discuté avec
eux pendant le blocus et encore
maintenant
et encore maintenant sur sont très
attachés au site nos étudiants vous
voyez c'est très beau passer une année
ici c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
ils sont très attachés au site est assez
valeur agronomique et écologique et donc
il
il est vrai que la vente les inquiète et
que l'avenir du site les inquiète et qui
souhaiteraient pouvoir en être acteur de
cet avenir et sur ce dossier le
département des yvelines a annoncé être
prêt à racheter les espaces boisés du
site afin de les transformer en espace
naturel sensible dans l'actualité
également une nuit de violences à
guyancourt des policiers des pompiers
ont été visés par des tirs de mortier et
des faits qui se sont produits lundi
soir et qui se sont poursuivies dans les
heures suivantes à chaque fois les
patrouilles ont été attaqués lors
d'interventions pour éloigner les
agresseurs les forces de l'ordre ont dû
faire usage d'armes de dispersion et
deuxième nuit consécutive de violences
dans la ville la veille à un
automobiliste avait foncé délibérément
sur un véhicule de police
c'est le rendez vous des acteurs de
l'innovation sur le territoire de paris
saclay paris saclay spring est au
programme les 20 et 21 mai prochains et
on en parle dans un instant avec notre
invité une édition 2021 avec une
nouveauté spring 50 c'est la sélection
des 50 startups les plus prometteuses
par michel roth caire qui est implantée
à montigny le bretonneux sa spécialité
le diagnostic de l'état du réseau
routier via smartphone cette solution
déjà opérationnelle poursuit son
développement découverte dans ce
reportage de justin brasier et de
nicolas landry elle a été créée en
février 2021 mais déjà reconnu dans le
monde de l'innovation road caire a été
sélectionné pour participer au spring
paris saclay le 20 et 21 mai prochains
cette start up est issu de l'entreprise
diagou est une société de diagnostic des
routes grâce à un camion et différents
dispositifs de mesure
roquet rapporte une nouvelle solution
innovante dans ce domaine or au caire
est une spin off de jag way et c'est la
version simplifiée du diagnostic routier
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas
moins de camions avec tous les
équipements on a juste besoin d'un
smartphone d'une application est la
nouveauté c'est que c'est également
directement la collectivité qui peut
réaliser le diagnostic en régie cette
solution facilite la gestion de la
compétence voirie pour les plus petites
collectivités locales l'utilisateur fixe
le téléphone sur le pare brise
il peut commencer son parcours les
voûtes étudiés sont captés à travers
l'application road caire pour récupère
la donner il a données collectées et
analysées sur nos serveurs par
l'intelligence artificielle
donc c'est là où tout l'inventaire se
fait des dégradations une poule les
fissures et toute la restitution se fait
ensuite sur sur une interface full web
dont le gestionnaire une fois de retour
au bureau se connecte avec son sommeil
et a accès à tout l'inventaire des
dégradations qui est réalisé aux notes
de bons mauvais moyens et aussi au plan
de travaux que l'on propose suite à ce
diagnostic est pour le moment on est
capable de faire toutes ces briques
métier de l'autre côté en attendant que
l'application en ligne soit 100%
opérationnel sa participation au spring
paris saclay une chance pour votre coeur
d'accélérer son développement et prendre
la route du déploiement sur les marchés
publics est invitée avec moi en
visioconférence jérémy hervé bonsoir
bon ça vous êtes le directeur de
l'innovation et du développement
économique de le paix à paris saclay
c'est l'établissement public
d'aménagement dont font partie notamment
le plateau de versailles satory à saint
quentin en yvelines alors le paris
saclay springs et le rendez vous cette
année 100% digitale 1 qui aura lieu lé
20 et 21 mai on l'a vu dans ce sujet une
nouveauté cette année c'est le sprint 50
la sélection des 50 start up du
territoire les plus prometteuses elles
vont être accompagnés pendant deux ans
par la french tech paris saclay et vont
bénéficier de leur propre stand lors de
l'événement pourquoi cette nouveauté
pourquoi justement donné cette
visibilité aux start up a tout
simplement à l'idée c'est de donner
toujours plus de visibilité à nos
startups pour qu'elles puissent
s'épanouir et se développer ici à paris
saclay où elles sont nées donc l'idée
c'était de dépasser une seule journée
par an pourquoi mettre la lumière sur
ces startups une seule journée par an
pourquoi pas toute l'année donc cette
sélection nous permettra toute l'année
d'identifier rapidement les start up a
présenté aux investisseurs sur d'autres
évènements sur d'autres exercices peut
pas seulement sur cette journée de ski
et parmi cette sélection 10 start up ont
été également retenus pour le pitch
conteste elles pourront présenter leurs
activités sur le plateau télé de
l'événement dans cette liste des 10
start up fait partie notamment la
start-up roadster comment ça va se
passer très concrètement ce pitch
conteste alors la piste quand est
d'habitude c'est une seule session lady
pictures se succèdent sur un an dans un
amphithéâtre sur une estrade cette année
évidemment avec la crise qu'on connaît
on est en distance yale et donc c'est
sur le plateau télé que viendront
intervenir les 10 start up qui ont été
retenues pour pitcher est en fait sur
cinq sessions donc il y aura cinq
sessions de deux pitch et à la fin de la
journée on remettra deux prix un prix du
jeu et qui est un jury professionnel et
un prix du coup de coeur du public
un revenant plus généralement sur
l'événement paris saclay spring deux
jours je le disais en 100% digitale pour
mettre en avant l'innovation autour de
cinq acteurs stratégiques la foutait clé
mobilité la technologie les technologies
numériques la green tech et la santé
biotech
l'objectif c'est quoi c'est de montrer
finalement toute la capacité dino
sion du territoire faire se rencontrer
aussi les acteurs qui composent ce
territoire tout à fait en fait l'idée
c'est au-delà donner de la visibilité à
nos startups
de donner aussi envie à d'autres
entreprises qui ne seront pas encore
avec nous de donner envie à des talons
de nous rejoindre de rejoindre cette
communauté d'innovation qui à paris
saclay pour ajouter à l'émulation et
puis apporter du sang neuf des idées
nouvelles des talents nouveaux donc
donner envie de nous rejoindre dans
cette communauté d'innovation et puis
c'est aussi une journée qui nous permet
de sensibiliser le tissu d'entreprises
déjà à paris saclay le tissu local de
pme de grands comptes
à la pause en jeu de l'open innovation
aux enjeux de la transition écologique
et la transformation digitale des
entreprises quelques chiffres
paris-saclay concentre près de 600
start-up 300 laboratoires de recherche
publics et privés des centres de r&d des
grands groupes et en tout 15 % de la
recherche publique et privée en france
il est concentré paris-saclay c'est
finalement un moteur de la relance après
la crise sanitaire la crise économique
c'est en tout cas l'ambition qui est qui
est affichée qui a porté oui nous
pensons réellement que l'innovation est
un levier de résilience économique du
nous pensons que c'est par l'innovation
que la france pourra rester en tête dans
la compétition économique mondiale
il faut constamment innover faire
toujours mieux améliorer l'état de l'art
et ça ça passe par la recherche
fondamentale la recherche appliquée et
donc on voit aussi que dans cette
période de pandémie ou le télétravail et
est de mise que il ya une fonction où le
télétravail reste quand même compliqué
où la proximité reste nécessaire avec
les partenaires assez d'innovations
l'expérimentation la recherche
donc voilà pour nous cette édition de
sprint ça va être l'occasion de
d'interroger de questionner la
pertinence d'appartenir à une communauté
d'innovation pour pouvoir mieux rebondir
ou rebondir plus vite en sortie de crise
on a évoqué tout à l'heure un petit peu
le programme avec notamment cette
nouveauté le sprint 50 je le disais deux
jours en 100% dit
le les 20 et 21 mai parmi les temps
forts on peut citer notamment la
présence du ministre de l'économie bruno
le maire qui participera à cet événement
oui en effet la nomine de l'économie
nous fera l'honneur de dire
l'introduction de prendre la parole en
ouverture le matin du plateau télé donc
ça c'est le jeudi 20 mai au matin
et puis ensuite on aura une table ronde
avec quatre de nos quatre représentants
de nos grands comptes industriels qui
fonda effet d ici à paris saclay et qui
ont eu des voiles à des projets
emblématiques du territoire est
justement de cette activité qui n'a pas
diminué au contraire pendant pendant la
crise d'autres rendez-vous des showrooms
du virtuel également au programme et
vendredi ce sont les circuits
l'innovation qui sont proposés de quoi
s'agit-il
très concrètement alors ça c'est une
partie qui reste essentiellement en
présentiel puisque les jauges à
sanitaire de permettent un sont des
visites en fait enfin la porte ouverte
donc des grands campus ii avait des
privés des laboratoires de recherche
publics vont ouvrir leurs portes
1 quelques petits groupes de quelques
personnes donc entre 5 et 20 personnes
selon les sites et leur permettre de
découvrir un grand lieu de l'innovation
ce qui d'habitude est tout à fait
impossible pour des raisons de
confidentialité il est extrêmement
difficile de visiter ces sites là donc
nous on donne l'opportunité aux
personnes qui s'inscrivent sur notre
événement de demander à participer à ces
circuits l'innovation donc c'est une
dizaine de sites en tout à la fois son
côté sonia et son côté blinois de paris
saclay et donc parmi les sites à visiter
par exemple le challenger de bouygues ou
l'observateur l'université d'assas saint
quentin en yvelines ou encore le futur
centre de recherche de servier sur le
campus urbain de paris saclay paris
saclay on le rappelle est à cheval sur
deux départements les yvelines d'un côté
et les sommes de l'autre
un dernier mot les ingrédients d'un
événement réussi quels sont ils
je pense qu'il faut des speakers de
qualité des gens qui connaissent très
bien leur domaine et puis et puis qui se
connaissent entre eux donc on est
vraiment dans une communauté
d'innovation
on a sélectionné les thèmes par rapport
aux technologies clés sur lesquels on
est très bien positionné à paris saclay
mais aussi qu'ils sont qui sont des
technologies clés qui vont re et
permettre de répondre aux grands enjeux
contemporains notamment climatiques
environnementaux et puis sociétaux et
donc je pense que la qualité des
speakers va rendre cette journée
absolument incroyable et ce sera donc
les 20 et 21 mai toutes les informations
sur ce paris saclay spring via le lien
le lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci jérémy hervé d'avoir été avec nous
le point à présent sur la vaccination
dans les yvelines au lundi 3 mai 283
1026 yvelinois avait reçu une première
injection quasi 27000 de plus en une
semaine 22 1682 rendez vous ont été pris
pour une vaccination cette semaine dont
près de death 17500 pour une seconde
dose pour rappel 16 centres de
vaccination sont ouverts dans les
yvelines
parmi eux le vaccinodromes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines installé dans
le vélodrome nationale où les 100000
vaccination vont être franchi ce
week-end
en parallèle l'agglomération travaille
sur un projet mettre en place une grande
enquête épidémiologique pour rendre plus
efficace la vaccination auprès des
habitants comprendre aussi le mécanisme
de l'immunité face au co vie de 19 chez
les personnes qui ont reçu des
injections un projet en partenariat avec
la communauté scientifique de paris
saclay l'institut pasteur l'inria et
l'inserm c'est en discussion en ce
moment également avec le ministère de la
santé on écoute à ce propos le président
de saint quentin en yvelines
interrogé par mélanie poké mais faut
anticiper nos missions est toujours
anticipé dans cette crise depuis le
départ et on veut continuer en faisant
une étude sur les gens qui viennent ici
et leur domaine pour les volontaires
s'il accepte d'avoir trois tests
sérologiques trois prises de sang sur 12
mois on comprenne comment
leur leurs anticorps sont maintenus ou
bien voilà c'est disparaissent on a
besoin de ça pour avoir une politique
derrière de vaccination encore plus
personnalisé plus adapté nous allons
parler à présent de l'histoire d'emma
début février 2021 cette jeune chinoise
de 8 ans chute lors d'un entraînement de
football et des examens révèlent par la
suite qu'elle souffre d'une tumeur
cérébrale après de la radiothérapie emma
va mieux mais son cancer est incurable
pour lui permettre de vivre plus
longtemps ses parents ont lancé une
collecte son papa on parle dans cette
interview réalisée par mélanie poké
c'est très dynamique à d'énergie
toujours joyeuse qui aime évidemment
s'amuser comme n'importe quel enfant de
son âge affirmé fait du foot elle c'est
une très bonne élève à l'école
la première langue étrangère du ski j'ai
été ce qu'il faut savoir c'est une
séance un cancer qui est pas pas curable
l'espérance de vie des enfants et de
neuf mois en moyenne à 2 ans le taux de
mortalité pratiquement 200 %
il existe plein de traitements efficaces
cure en france ni même à l'étranger
il n'existe pas de cure aujourd'hui il
ya juste créé tu mens expérimentaux
j'ai fait d'autres recherches et
notamment aux états unis
il se pourrait qu'il ya un traitement
qu'il soit plus adapté que certaines
donc longue de son un produit par l'axé
sociétés dont cosmetics a beaucoup de
français l'ont secrètement beaucoup de
familles françaises me donnent à leurs
enfants
aux etats unis le système de santé il
est payant et pas comme en france et
vous avez des frais d'hospitalisation et
les frères test qui ils peuvent
atteindre tout de suite atteindre tout
de suite des sommes assez extraordinaire
à versailles la rue des chantiers est
partiellement fermée à la circulation et
ce jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
il s'agit de la partie entre les rues
jean mermoz et albert sarraut
conséquences de la fuite d'eau déceler
hier lundi provoquée par la rupture
d'une canalisation en souterrain 300
foyers avaient été privés d'eau en début
d'après midi
si l'eau potable est rétabli les dégâts
causés sont sur la voirie sont très
importants est la route est inutilisable
des travaux de reconstruction vont avoir
lieu au plus vite
indique la mairie de versailles et
direction ou dans pour refermer ce
journal ou un couple d'agriculteurs va
ouvrir sa boutique à la ferme
prochainement entre adaptation avec la
crise sanitaire besoin de renouer le
contact et regain pour la production
locale la fraiseraie de houdan se tient
prête le reportage d'eléonore sinoquet
damien et stéphanie van haltes sont
prêts la fiche port du masque
obligatoire la distanciation sociale et
le sens de circulation attendent les
clients dans leurs boutiques à la ferme
dès le 10 mai la fraiseraie de houdan
rouvrira ses portes après une année
d'adaptation avec la crise sanitaire
le couple d'agriculteurs veut renouer le
contact
l'année dernière on a dû s'adapter un
petit peu dans l'urgence on a fait un
drive en fait donc
un drive les gens venez en voiture après
on trouve ça un petit peu dommage
notre objectif en faisant de la vente
directe c'est quand même de voir le
consommateur ait pu parler donc cette
année on a dit bon on connaît un peu
mieux le covin donc on prendra les
mesures barrières tout ce qu'il faut
pour être dans les normes sanitaires par
contre on veut rediscuter avec les
clients les gens ont besoin de contacter
contact avec les clients mais aussi
regard vers la production locale
la crise sanitaire a remis au goût du
jour l'achat de fruits et légumes de
saison et surtout près de chez soi
la production locale ou tient à coeur
parce que je pense que c'est important
de revenir au juste valeur là on a
l'impression que les tout le monde
redécouvre la production locale donc
c'est une bonne chose
plus que jamais la fraiseraie de houdon
tient pas sa production cette année
treize mille cinq cents pieds de
fraisiers ont à nouveau été plantée avec
six variétés différentes de fraises mais
le couple van halst a aussi tenu à se
diversifier
on s'est lancé dans la myrtille parce
qu'aujourd'hui la myrtille c'est un
fruit qui est en vogue qui est très
consommée est très demandé et seulement
10% de la production et française donc
c'est quand même dommage d'acheter de la
myrtille du pérou du chili
sachant qu'on peut potentiellement
produire en france donc on va découvrir
cette production en 2021 seulement
quelques grammes sortiront de cette
nouvelle production dès l'an prochain en
revanche les myrtilles côtoieront les
fraises au sein de la boutique à la
ferme c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]